Hey guys, so a few weeks ago I made a video called
"Stop Saying No."
And it's about all the times where I would say
no to new experiences in my life or to going out
to just kind of being like at home alone and never
really doing anything different.
But that video kind of like sparked this conversation
about all the people who struggle with saying no.
And so I wanted to talk about that today.
And I don't know about you but for me
I struggle a lot with saying no when people ask me
to do something or when they need something from me.
Whether it's a stranger
Hey there, I'm so sorry to trouble you but could
my friends and I catch a ride with you?
Not if you're any less polite!
Ahaha, great!
Thank you so much.
Now drive or I'll shoot you like a rusted tin can on a wooden fence!
Drive!
Okay!
Or my friend.
Oh my God, I'm not asking you for a lot.
I'm just asking you to elaborately stage my death
so when I reveal myself, my boyfriend can learn to really listen.
Well...
Or my cat.
But you already ate.
But as I've gotten older, and more confident
and wiser, I'm starting to become a lot more comfortable with this idea
that it is okay to draw a line with people.
You know?  It's totally fine to say that you don't want to do something.
Hey there, I'm so sorry to trouble you but
could my friends and I catch a ride with you?
Okay, all right.
Back it up.  Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Or that you're uncomfortable.
I just think that's kind of a dick thing to do.
Well how else is he suppose to learn how to really listen?
Or to just create a boundary.
The vet said you're too fat.
What about you?  Do you find it hard to say no?
When do you find it hard to say no?
Or are you just like totally self assured and you don't care
about turning people down?
Let me know below!
I have a few live shows coming up if you guys
are in the Los Angeles area.  We do like little meet-and-greets
afterwards and we have an insane photoshoot with all of the people there.
So you should come!
And I also have two short films coming out this Summer
One is called "Supers & Associates" which is a superhero comedy
and one is called "Loose Ends" which is a thriller
and crazy stuff happens.
And also Ghosts and Stars has a bunch of new Summer stuff in!
Like this!  The Chill Out cool cat shirt and a bunch of rompers
so if you want to check out my clothingline, feel free!
And I want to say thank you to NuMe for sponsoring today's episode.
They sent me this glorious pentacle wand that you can
cast spells with.
But I love the NuMe Wand because it's such great quality.
I can use this wand for years.
And I love the ceramic magic technology of it all
because I have like thick Asian hair that will not hold curls.
But whenever I curl my hair with one of their products
it will last for a good like 2 days.
Which is awesome because I hate doing touch ups.
They also sent me some Argan oil
which is like anti-frizz heat serum protectant.
And my hair just looks so shiney and nice when I put it in.
It's just like I'm a queen.
So thanks so much to NuMe.
You guys can use the code PentacleMagic
to get $100 off of any curling set
or, if you just want one wand, you can use the code Unicorns
to get any wand for $39.00.
I'll have those in the description box if you're interested.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.